[Música]
y
la jueza que tan liberal jackson hace
historia y se convertirá en la primera
afroamericana en la corte suprema de
justicia de eeuu tras ser confirmada por
el senado con el voto de tres
republicanos tenemos reportes desde
washington
en el día 43 de la invasión rusa ucrania
las autoridades ucranianas aseguraron
que en la ciudad devoró dianca la
situación es más terrible que en la
cercana lucha los ataques rusos se
concentran ahora en el este del país
plantea elige este domingo presidente 12
candidatos se disputa en el puesto más
importante del país en fresas 24 les
estaremos actualizando con una emisión
especial desde las 12 de bogotá quito y
lima
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 s rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos esta
emisión en eeuu porque el senado
confirmó a qué tangi brawn jackson como
jueza de la corte suprema- marcando un
hito en la historia al ser la primera
afroestadounidense en la máxima
autoridad judicial de la nación 50
congresistas demócratas y tres
republicanos votaron a su favor frente a
los 47 votos en contra aún está
pendiente la ratificación en la cámara
de representantes donde los demócratas
tienen la mayoría
más temprano nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal basket nos contó
cómo se ha vivido la votación pues se
quedan y brawn de jackson estaba en la
casa blanca que está acá detrás
esperando esta votación en el senado de
estos tres republicanos la apoyaron la
votación se esperaba iba a ser en línea
partidista es decir los republicanos
votando en contra los demócratas a favor
pero los demócratas tienen esa mayoría
simple de 51 votos sin embargo estos 3
senado y republicanos susan collins de
maine lisa murkowski de alaska y mitt
romney ex candidato presidencial por
yuta la apoyaron y entonces qué tan
g.brown jackson se convierte así en la
primera mujer afroamericana en llegar a
la corte suprema de justicia el proceso
duró 42 días este este periodo es menor
a el periodo que normalmente dura un
periodo de confirmación a la corte
suprema sobre todo teniendo en cuenta el
último que se vivió acá en estados
unidos que fue el del juez cubano que
duró varios meses es de resaltar también
pues que tania brawn y acciones será la
juez a la corte suprema la más joven de
los nueve magistrados que hay en esta
esta institución estadounidense que vela
por la justicia
en el día 43 de guerra en ucrania las
denuncias de atrocidades cometidas por
las fuerzas rusas contra la población
civil ucraniana siguen aumentando a
medida que las tropas de ucrania retoman
el control de algunas ciudades el
mandatario ucraniano señaló que las
masacres cometidas en boro dianca
podrían ser aún más terribles que en
lucha donde decenas de cuerpos de
civiles continúan esparcidos en las
calles de la ciudad marina sardiña tiene
los detalles
una ciudad completamente en ruinas bajo
los escombros según denuncian las
autoridades ucranianas hay al menos 26
cuerpos de civiles por odian acá a poco
más de 70 kilómetros de la capital kiev
alberga el horror de 43 días de guerra
en ucrania las autoridades ucranianas
alertaron además de que el número de
víctimas causadas por las tropas rusas
sería mayor que en cualquier otro lugar
significativamente mucho más espantoso
allí aún más víctimas de los ocupantes
sean rusos qué pasará cuando el mundo
conozca toda la verdad sobre lo que
hicieron los militares sean rusos en
mariupol allí en casi todas las calles
está lo que se vio en lucha y otras
ciudades de la región de kiev tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas la misma
crueldad y los mismos crímenes terribles
casos tukis aquí se transmitió el jueves
del jefe humanitario de naciones unidas
visitó una fosa común en buche y
occidente ha condenado la muerte de
civiles durante su invasión las
autoridades de ucrania denuncian que el
ejército ruso asesinó a más de 300
personas varios días después los
cadáveres de decenas de civiles
ucranianos continúan cubriendo las
calles muchos han sido enterrados por
sus vecinos en los jardines de sus
mismas casas dulce la unión no está
eslovenia una buena amiga vivíamos cerca
el uno del otro en el primer piso lo en
ya fue asesinada delante de nosotros
este grupo de voluntarios ayuda a
recoger los cuerpos más de 30 cada día
nos llevan a un cementerio para su
identificación y sepultura
[Música]
todos estos son personas asesinadas y
torturadas disparados a quemarropa con
los brazos y las piernas atados algunos
les vendaron los ojos al final hay seis
personas fusiladas y quemadas todas
juntas
mientras tanto los combates más feroces
se mantienen en el sureste del país
mariupol más de 100.000 civiles siguen
atrapados bajo la artillería rusa
entretanto a la comunidad internacional
sigue presionando a través de sanciones
para lograr una desescalada del
conflicto rusia fue suspendida del
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
una medida que moscú critica por ilegal
al tiempo que fue bienvenida por ucrania
mientras que la unión europea impuso un
embargo el carbón ruso
una decisión trascendental el 7 de abril
rusia fue suspendida del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu bajo el
argumento de violaciones y abusos
sistemáticos cometidos durante su
invasión a ucrania en facebook line the
tree el resultado es el siguiente a
favor 93 en contra 24 abstenciones 58 el
proyecto de resolución se adopta y
previo a la votación los representantes
de ucrania y rusia se pronunciaron en
estos días
todo lo que necesita hacer es presionar
el botón sirve para el consejo de
derechos humanos y muchas vidas en
el brain rating presionar no significa
apretar un gatillo
hoy no es el momento ni el lugar para el
teatro o este tipo de actuaciones como
la presentada por ucrania si kiev estilo
priísta club cry a través de un
comunicado el gobierno ruso rechazó
suspensión la parte rusa considera que
la resolución adoptada por la asamblea
general de la onu el 7 de abril en nueva
york para suspender la membresía del
federación rusa en el consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu es un paso
ilegal y políticamente motivado para
castigar desafiantemente a un estado
miembro soberano de la onu a más de
5.800 kilómetros de nueva york- en
bruselas los ministros de relaciones
exteriores de los países miembros de la
otan debatían sobre más ayudas para
ucrania y condenaron lo ocurrido en la
ciudad ucraniana de bushehr
doctor y más hemos acordado que debemos
fortalecer y mantener aún más nuestro
apoyo a ucrania para que el país
prevalezca frente a la invasión rusa y
tendréis pese a que las esperanzas están
puestas en encontrar una solución a
través del diálogo los integrantes del
g7 anuncian nuevas sanciones económicas
y financieras en contra de rusia al
tiempo que el parlamento europeo votó en
favor de una resolución para pedir
sanciones adicionales entre ellas un
embargo total a las importaciones de
petróleo gas y carbón procedente de
rusia
nos vamos ahora hasta perú porque allí
se vivió una nueva jornada de protestas
en contra de la gestión del gobierno de
pedro castillo estas movilizaciones
nacieron por el alza en los precios de
los combustibles y derivaron en un
reclamo general al presidente nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
nos resumía previamente la jornada
las confederaciones sindicales obreros y
la educación realizaron una jornada
nacional de lucha para exigir al
presidente pedro castillo adoptar
acciones más adecuadas para enfrentar
qué afecta a la vida de millones de
peruanos debido al incremento de los
combustibles y de los productos de la
canasta básica familiar los
manifestantes se movilizaron por las
principales calles de lima se sienten
desilusionados con castillos que exigen
al mandatario frenar la inflación acabar
con la imposición de medidas
improvisadas como el inconstitucional
'toque de queda' del martes 5 de abril
luchar contra la corrupción defender la
economía popular y cubiertos sus
promesas electorales
gobierno después de un fuerte
contingente policial en riesgo el
palacio del gobierno y el entorno del
parlamento para evitar desmanes de la
marcha premios emmy arrastrarse al
mandatario izquierdista por no haber
ejecutado acciones para enfrentar al
neoliberalismo lo acusan de
supuestamente haber negociado con
sectores de derecha para mantenerse en
el cargo durante el cubrimiento de estas
jornadas algunos ciudadanos me dijeron
que las protestas continuarán mientras
pedrosa casey o no realice mejoras que
les permita salir del estancamiento
social y económico en el que perú se
encuentra actualmente
vamos a colombia y las lluvias
torrenciales han dejado al menos 12
fallecidos debido a una inundación
repentina las autoridades informaron
también de al menos ocho heridos y dos
desaparecidos en el departamento de
antioquia en el noreste del país las
inundaciones son comunes en colombia en
época de lluvias sin embargo según el
departamento administrativo de gestión
del riesgo de desastres no había alerta
de emergencia en la zona y las víctimas
no tuvieron tiempo para reaccionar
y en honduras los transportistas también
bloquearon las principales vías del país
exigen implementar un subsidio estatal
para evitar el aumento del precio del
combustible dennis herrera tiene los
detalles
en honduras transportistas bloquearon
las calles de las principales ciudades
del país demandan un subsidio estatal
para contrarrestar el aumento en los
precios de los combustibles causado por
la guerra en ucrania así como un aumento
en la tarifa de sus servicios la
presidenta aseguró que las
manifestaciones son injustificadas el
paro de transporte es totalmente
injustificado rebaje 10 y 13 lempiras al
10 el más de 4.000 millones protestar es
un derecho parar la circulación es un
acto ilegal penado por la ley y
representa un boicot a mi gobierno no
hay diálogo hasta que suspendan el paro
castro agregó que una comisión recibirá
los transportistas en la casa de
gobierno para que presenta sus
alternativas ante la crisis del
combustible que alcanza precios
históricos el galón de premium marcó los
4,94 dólares el regular 461 y el diésel
449 el gobierno ha bajado los precios de
entre 40 y 50 centavos la reducción en
las tarifas de la gasolina fue una
promesa de castro en campaña que
enfrenta su primera crisis importante
desde que asumió el gobierno el 27 de
enero desde el gobierno anterior el de
juan orlando hernández los
transportistas exigen
y dio estatal y nos vamos hasta el
salvador porque unicef denunció que las
medidas decretadas por el gobierno de
najib bukele para luchar contra las
pandillas han resultado en detenciones y
condenas a menores de edad que según el
organismo de las naciones unidas-
perpetúan los ciclos de violencia
exclusión y pobreza en el país con la
ley en la mano los menores de entre 12 y
15 años podrían enfrentarse hasta 10
años de prisión
y españa y marruecos pactaron la
reapertura gradual y ordenada de las
fronteras de ceuta y melilla uno de los
principales acuerdos que llegan en la
renovada relación bilateral entre ambos
países vecinos la noticia llega luego de
la visita oficial a rabat del presidente
del gobierno español pedro sánchez
concertada tras el reconocimiento de
españa a la propuesta marroquí para la
autonomía del sáhara occidental' estas
fueron las palabras de sánchez creo que
este es un momento histórico es un
momento también necesario para ambos
países en la definición de nuestras
relaciones bilaterales
vamos a proceder a la reapertura
progresiva de los pasos fronterizos para
garantizar un flujo ordenado de personas
con seguridad y de acuerdo a los
requisitos sanitarios necesarios
y las mercancías también van a circular
con normalidad
vamos a israel ahí el primer ministro e
naftalí bennett envió las condolencias a
las familias de las al menos dos
personas que perdieron la vida y las
otras seis que resultaron heridas en
medio de un tiroteo registrado en varios
puntos de tel aviv las autoridades
indicaron que él pechos o aún se
encuentra a la fuga el grupo islamista
hamás celebró el ataque se trata del
cuarto atentado en las últimas dos
semanas y con las dos víctimas de hoy 13
personas han muerto en medio de hechos
similares durante el último mes más
temprano nuestro corresponsal en
jerusalén federico cuevas verena nos
explicaba más sobre esta ola de
terrorismo
cuarto ataque armado en israel en poco
más de dos semanas pero está impactada
por el escenario la calle dice en pleno
centro de tel aviv el atacante abrió
fuego en el popular mar ica y disparó en
otras zonas antes de darse a la fuga
algo que tampoco es habitual muchas
personas permanecieron fuera pese a la
orden policial de quedarse dentro de sus
hogares mientras que oficiales de grupos
de palestinos hamas y la yihad islámica
saludaron el ataque aunque sin
adjudicarse su autoría este episodio
recuerda al atentado del primero de
enero de 2016 en la misma calle
dizengoff que causó la muerte de dos
jóvenes la atención en israel igualmente
ya estaba alta por los tres atentados
desde finales de marzo en beni brack
cadera inmersiva que causaron un total
de 11 víctimas desde entonces las
autoridades israelíes han lanzado
redadas en comunidades árabes y
palestinas que se han saldado con al
menos seis palestinos muertos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
israelíes por otro lado el gobierno
también ha reforzado la presencia de
efectivos en la ciudad vieja de
jerusalén durante la celebración del
ramadán y las detenciones son moneda
corriente casi cada noche este ataque
también supone una nueva prueba para el
primer ministro naftalí bennett
debilitado esta semana tras perder la
frágil mayoría de su coalición en la que
el parlamento israelí francia elige este
domingo a su próximo presidente para un
mandato de cinco años 12 candidatos
aspiran a llegar al palacio del elíseo
ganará el aspirante que obtenga la
mayoría absoluta más del 50% de los
votos en la primera vuelta de lo
contrario habrá una segunda vuelta entre
los dos más votados que si este año es
necesaria será el próximo 24 de abril
los invitamos este 10 de abril a
conectarse con nuestro especial a partir
del mediodía hora de bogotá quito y lima
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]